heute ist der große tag leute heute
geht's los dieses jahr startet glocken
das mit dem adventskalender den ich für
timo macht
ein highlight dieser band können heute
sehr starr band
und was macht man am ersten advent man
färbt sich natürlich seine haare
[Musik]
ich werde aussehen wie ein geheimagent
ich hasse es jetzt schon mit diesem
scheiß leser
[Musik]
oder nicht richtig lecker richtig lecker
ich würde euch gerne draußen zeigen aber
und schneidet ist meine erste reaktion
des partners tag
es gibt gerade anfangen zu schneien und
das ist wirklich ein immer größeres
locken auch was haben die für monopoly
das ist ein ganz anderes monopoly
jaja so holz in goldfolie drauf sie
haben hunger
ich habe frühstück bestellt und ich habe
es noch nie mitbekommen aber teams
reaktion war einfach
runde gruppe modus aber ich hatte so
bock aufs frühstück wacker bismarck das
wusste ich nicht
da stand nicht das ist ein salat dazu
wirbt das wusste ich auch nicht
island mmm mmm entwendet so käser tust
und bauernfrühstück und das dann habe
ich mich gestellt das sind 63 oder viel
meine gleichen sachen mit brötchen und
allem drum und dran das habe ich aber
womöglich nicht bestehen
ich habe die retourkutsche für alkohol
bekommt na klar das ding ist ich kann
mich gar nicht daran erinnern dass also
wir haben zu wenig getrunken glaube weil
wir halt so lange nicht getrunken haben
im november ist unsere toleranz total
niedrig wir brauchen nur sehr wenig aber
ich nackt bin ich bin nackt und rede mit
und so immer wenig verkatert bin oder
voran getrunken habe und mich am
nächsten tag deswegen nicht gut fühle
brauche ich etwas und mich besser zu
fühlen ich habe herausgefunden dass man
in anderen kulturen ländern kauf hautton
ich bin und kopfhaut honig ist halt wie
tonic fürs gesicht das soll reinigen und
pflegen weil an kopfhaut denkt man
anscheinend nicht genug
und dann habe ich noch so ein ding
geholt was sie kopfhaut massiert also
beim waschen nimmt man das quasi beim
shampoonieren und shampoo jetzt so den
kopf und dann sollte man eine gute
kopfhaut kriegen ich weiß nicht wie viel
man mit seiner kopfhaut machen darf ob
man das überhaupt machen darf aber
probieren es einfach mal aus national
sein
ok dann viel spaß und jetzt beim baden
zu
hier soll bade sein und mein busen
zu stehen
ganz wichtig
ich hoffe ich melde mich gleich mit
schöner rambach müssen wir viel besser
geht als mir geht es natürlich nicht gut
und das ist einfach komplett meine
eigene schuld trinkst gestern schon
nicht so gut und dann hatte ich
irgendwie 233 gläser wein hat ich glaube
ich und dann war ich einfach ich aber
nicht so groß gewesen so kleine gläser
ist einfach dumm thema geht aber auch
nicht so gut weil ich euch das material
gezeigt haben dann noch gefilmt haben
es ging es dann noch gestern wirkte weil
ich gemacht daumen berger und x3 ja ich
gebe es in die badewanne us-film mich
jetzt aber nicht
jetzt geht es mir richtig gut jetzt bin
ich richtig tiefenentspannt badewanne
hat sehr sehr gut getan weiß gar nicht
wie viel dieses kopfhaut dingen widmen
ich liebe es wenn man sich so richtig
zeit dafür lässt zum pflegen als sonst
erledigt man das etwas wie sehr unsere
pflicht vor unsere gesellschaftliche
pflicht dass wir nicht stinken und das
wir gefühl durch den tag gehen deswegen
ist das halt immer so ich muss mich
schnell waschen aber wenn man sich
wirklich so wäscht und das so richtig
das ist gut aber niemand seinen profi
angeguckt
bewertet man sein profil nicht ganz
sicher ob man das sind nasse haare
trockene haare oder whatever machen soll
durch den film operation geglückt war
habe ich so viele wünsche frei also zwei
wimpern im auge ist schon krass
ja durch habe mir so ein bambus
wattestäbchen im ohr habe leute ihr
putzt auch nur eure außenschale hier
diesen bereich oder weil ich habe früher
noch in der kindheit das immer rein
gesteckt und dann halt so vorsichtig in
meinem ohr um gefummelt aber jetzt
bekommt dass man das ja überhaupt nicht
machen soll
also wirklich nur diese außen muschel
und vielen eingang aber nicht mehr also
nur das was quasi rauskommt im videos
gesehen von verstopften ohrlöcher von so
jahrelang zeug was da irgendwie sich
angesammelt hat und was nie was immer
nur rein gestoppt wurde und seitdem
nehme ich das ernst und weiß okay machen
muss es wirklich vorsichtig saubermachen
jetzt probieren wir mal unser hier an so
coole neue sache aus das riecht nach
minze
es riecht sehr gut dass ich vermute aber
dass man die ganze treffer damit der
nicht entwischen kann weil aber das
frage ich eigentlich lebt man nun jahren
intensiv man nicht rausgehen kann kann
man sich mal seine kopfhaut dann meine
kopfhaut kribbelt seine kopfhaut fühlt
sich kalt an
halt es normal weil es mintzel ich habe
jetzt ein bisschen 1 aber ich bin noch
einen kleinen saal wenn ich rot wäre ein
komisches gefühl das habe ich noch nie
wie vervollständigen unsere beauty
ich mache jetzt eine gesichtsmaske die
gesichtsmaske hatte ich im koreanischen
adventskalender und ich muss echt sagen
ich liebe sie also weiß nie was genau
welche produkte bringen aber solange man
spaß bei der verwendung und so hat wohin
hat
[Musik]
die riechen bis in die heilerde also
gericht sehr natürlich
[Musik]
wenn man sich sehr gestresst fühlt dann
kann man lavendelöl verwenden also pures
lavendelöl dann gebt ihr euch ein
tropfen auf die adler fördern sie meinen
unterstreicht das miteinander und dann
habt ihr die ganze zeit bei bewegungen
die ihr macht orderte von der wendel der
beruf nicht in stent ansonsten machst du
das noch sonstwas selbst mal hier vorbei
da kann doch irgendwas verbrennen
ich hab ein türchen für heute noch nicht
aufgemacht es ist jetzt mein handy nicht
zeigen mir darin nachrichten brauchen
wir nicht leben dürfte sind sie meine
plötzlich und ich hab natürlich noch
nicht ausgemacht jeden tag haben leute
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
verarscht mich die ganze zeit der tut
immer so viel zu krasse du machst viel
zu kassel
das ding ist wieder voll wie nichts
anderes so voll wie ich gestern nie so
voll war bin ich ich habe jemanden also
immer hat geschrieben wegen der
verpackung ich weiß nicht welche war die
alle auf mein gott genau das brauche ich
heute rahmen suppe eine scharfe rahmen
so gelindert alle symptome die du hast
die bots bohn in sämtlichen
geschmacksrichtungen sind die netten die
jelly beans
ja gut so paetsch habe ich ihm auch
reingepackt also kann es sein dass ich
denke dass erster patch freude ist und
er denkt ich esse sehr gerne
und eigentlich ist keine von fitch zu
jahren lag beim thema sind ich habe
zitronenwasser ausgedrückt und machen
wir sind anti kater mitteln und und
diese bestellung heute morgen habe ich
noch mit süßigkeiten gekauft
extrem comedy auch ausprobieren die
trolli extrem sauer bald die geile aus
ich denke die irgendwie so suchen sie
sich kein paket gekauft er bestimmt gab
es bei amazon paketen zu mehreren
süßigkeiten
[Musik]
ja ich war schockiert über die salate
wir haben jetzt vier von denen und
solche oliven dinge so viel verpackung
und plastik bekommt schon der
retourkutsche dafür dass ich zu faul war
um mir ein brot zu schmieren heute
morgen
[Musik]
also wenn ich meinen fuß bewerten müsste
es war ein bisschen öl ich aber sehr gut
ist sehr nett und das war auch sehr
lecker
[Musik]
flüssig ist ich weiß dass ich mit timo
sowas mit sowas einfach eine freude ist
einfach glücklicher wenn er das sie
hierzu die menschen nicht so wichtig ist
also wenn es ordentlich oder
[Musik]
oh mein gott die gail sie hat wirklich
gesagt viel spaß beim yoga weil ich eine
yogamatte in der hand hatte und sich
einfach nicht immer so die tür aufmachen
die leute denken ich bin total sportlich
inaktiv lange kann ich verraten wo timo
überhaupt ist oder also kino ist nicht
hier bei timo einem freund bei einem
umzug hilft sie dürfen das natürlich nur
alleine machen wird sich auch nach
berlin
also irgendwie ziehen gerade alle
menschen mit dem wir zu tun haben nach
berlin sind
das war die sache in der maske die ich
benutzt aber die trockenen auch häuser
weil ich auf meinem kopf
mir fällt auf ich habe euch das
wichtigste noch gar nicht erzählt und
zwar ich habe ein tagen darum bestellt
der kommt am samstag mehr sage ich erst
mal dazu nicht aber dann seht ihr auf
jeden fall sonntag wie wir den
weihnachtsbaum schmücken ich freue mich
da extrem darauf ich weiß auch nicht
warum aber ich habe mir das jetzt für
nikolaus dann vorgenommen und ja aber
sollte schon tannenbaum stehen ich weiß
manche stellen den ersten zwei tage
bevor
heiligabend auf ich finde man kann ihn
nicht lang genug haben und mir ist eine
sache aufgefallen und ich sage mir dass
jeden tag dass ich das machen möchte
aber irgendwie bin ich halt auch einfach
nicht so eine shopping queen
ich mag es nicht so gerne klamotten
einzukaufen ich glaube das liegt auch
daran dass ich früher halt nicht so viel
geld hatte und das nicht so gewohnt bin
klamotten zu kaufen ich habe sachen
bekommen und dann habe ich die langen
getragen und dann gab es nichts neues
und jetzt bin ich erwachsen und habe
mein eigenes geld aber ich gebe es
trotzdem bin ich auch ich habe drei
weihnachts police und ich bin so ein
riesen weihnachts verändert ich dachte
haben ja weihnachts klamotten also
wirklich was ist mit diesen herren warum
sind die denn so tut also nicht die sind
so fein dass hatten diese scheiß
massieren und tonic oder das hat meine
kopfhaut gemeint da gucke ich gerade bei
elsers und eigentlich doch nur so
christmas eingeben und mit damen
weihnachts polizei
die haben sogar eine abteilung dafür bin
ich ein begriff das problem ist bei
diesen weihnachten
die sind nicht dafür ausgelegt da wir
produzieren eine klamotte die grenzen
kann sondern auch keine gute qualität
aber du trägst das ja in nur drei
monaten weihnachten ein bisschen schade
hier kann ich mich gerade nicht
entscheiden ob ich den wunderschön finde
oder potthässlich er würde dafür tragen
so ernstgemeint gucken wir mal beim
konkurrenten zalando viel liebe ich
eigentlich schon der ist mein gott
jackson aus verkauf komplett ist dann
angezeigt wenn es ausverkauft ist das
verstehe ich nicht will ich will den
salat wirklich sehr sehr süße grüße
sachen besteht ein paar christmas die
outfits und werde euch dann im laufe der
tage mal vorstellen
hier seht ihr was wir fünf mal bekommen
haben und das gleiche
die schmiere ich mir jetzt ich sag mal
so deutsche handwerkskunst
dann schaue ich blog mass von so eller
heute morgen habe ich nämlich schon die
erste folge guckt jetzt habe ich gesehen
dass der zweite tag online ist und ich
bin ich gucke mir das ist einfach an
ich glaube ich brauche wieder ein
bisschen diese so erweiterte meinem blog
meine glockner sind so ein bisschen zu
ende sagt mal selber also man würde doch
also oder beziehungsweise ich mag es
auch viel weihnachtliches zu sehen und
ich habe jetzt in letzter zeit nicht
viel weihnachtliches gezeigt
rasieren wir probieren mal den honig
das ist es das leckerste je gesehen habe
tolle kreationen so das wird dann so
zusammengepresst und ordentlich fliesst
kein ko nicht raus es geht drunter geht
runter wie öl
die schau geht blog mit weihnachtliches
passiert aber ich glaube trotzdem hoch
aber halt trotzdem buchladen auch wenn
nicht spannendes passiert so richtig
gemütlich jetzt auf die couch prägt und
sein komisches bild in essen so ich
konnte nicht abwarten
unbedingt probieren des looks kleidung
also ich weiß dass ich kein trainer bin
dieses jahr werde ich wieder an kopf
rennen sein ich mich irgendwie komplett
vom kochen abgewendet habe auch nicht
woran das lag ich glaube ich war zu
überfressen an überfressen einfach ich
war einfach zu überfordert von den
ganzen mittwoch buch und pipapo
übrigens mein kochbuch ein perfektes
weihnachtsgeschenk
ok ich zeige ich jetzt was sie sehr sehr
cool findet landen wir am ende mal hier
ich bin richtig auf einem kreativen
modus so ich hab was also ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich bin mir nicht sicher
was es überhaupt ist
wie ein filmset perfektes küchen für ein
adventskalender
das ist ein filz cartoon kappel needle
verdingkind gold brille also ich quasi
und ich weiß aus wie also fehlt das sind
wahrscheinlich die haare
also ich habe das hier ich denke mal
dass es die goldene brille die ich
basteln kann ich denke mal ich habe
wieder aber okay und hier ist der
anleitung das sind ich es ja gut die
anleitung ist auf koreanisch und man
kann sie sogar schminken also so soll
sie aussehen am ende in meinem fall noch
mit brille wenn das total interessant
weil ich das noch nie gemacht habe er
tat sowie keine pizza würde was muss man
denn da für eine das bringt mir denn so
ein scheiß sein weil sie keine filstal
und ich hab mal eine filz name gehabt
habe ich mit meiner fans nadel gemacht
ich habe keine filz nadel gut dann ist
das ein projekt für später irgendwann
nicht hatten kleine finale dabei sein
wird meine film-karriere muss warten
dann muss ich mir den film anschauen und
bei diesen nudeln ist dass die so
richtig scharf sind ja gut und jeder der
wirklich schade sind kann sagt diese
strähne dass das mich nicht los wie
entspannt hier einfach vorn
ich verspreche euch ab morgen geht s
richtig mit den christmas i feelings los
am morgen mache ich viel mehr
weihnachtliche aktionen ich würde auch
keine lust mehr mir das hier zu versauen
und wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder